when did you realize you found the
perfect form of carbon spy Tom check
never laureate in chemistry 1989 well
I'm not sure I guess it is perfect
because c60 is a pure carbon molecule
whereas diamond and graphite have got to
have dangling bonds on the surface and
on the edges but I think it really was
on a Tuesday morning on the monday we
had discussed what it might be and we
discussed but mr. Fuller's domes that
maybe this carbon molecule which would
seem to have strength was a sphere and
that it was related and I had a star
dome back home in England and we went
out for to a restaurant that evening and
I remembered describing the stardome had
not just hexagons but also Pentagon's
and I was thinking of calling my wife up
asking you know to find this model of
the stardome that I had to see whether
it has 60 vertices and but I didn't do
that but that night Rick Cox out
hexagons and tried to make it and
couldn't make it and then he remembered
I'd said that think the structure had
Pentagon's and when he put the
Pentagon's it magically curled up and
the next morning came in with this
beautiful a wonderful little paper ball
and I think we were all totally ecstatic
and realized that this was something
special and then we realize it was a
soccer ball and at that point I think it
must be right it was just too beautiful
to be wrong a little bit later I started
to have the odd ? because half a dozen
papers came out just just after hours to
say we were wrong but then I playing
around with little modeling kit and
realized if 60
was the right answer then 70 which is an
unusual number should be the next favors
structure and I call it so like Don
Quixote and Sancho Panza or Batman and
Robin alone Ranger and Tonto and in fact
that turned out to be correct so it was
ecstatic the day of realizing what it
might be and then a few months later
realizing that if 70 was also strong and
a favorite feature than it it must be
correct